[Musique]
nous avons des policiers qui se déplacent
vers le peuple américain
[Musique]
le monde a été blessé votre tollé
face à cette opération d'état le monde se
tient à vos côtés et aux
responsables américains et à la police
arrêtez la violence contre votre peuple et
laissez-les  la paix
bien ce que je dirais, c'est que les adversaires de l'amérique,
ils s'amusent avec les
développements aux états-unis,
je pense qu'ils en ont profité
et que l'administration de l'atout est
vulnérable aux critiques, il est
clair que l'accent n'est pas mis sur un
public national mais  plutôt que c'est
une opportunité de marquer des points
euh à l'international euh
pour souligner euh ce qu'ils croient
voir comme de l'hypocrisie dans la position américaine
[Musique] [
Musique]
est [
Musique] [
Musique]
bâtiment étranger
[Musique]
je veux dire je pense que l'administration  va
se retrouver dans une position très difficile, le
problème est qu'étant donné le
langage et les réponses de Trump chez lui aux
États-Unis, ils ne sonnent pas
vrai, ils sont pour beaucoup de gens, ils n'auront pas
le même genre de crédibilité